so one of the most requests of video
series that I receive is the Cthulhu
Mythos the work of HP Lovecraft and all
those that followed and to be honest
with you I don't really know why I
haven't covered the work of HP Lovecraft
before but I think before I delve into
the Cthulhu Mythos I should first
discuss the man behind it all some of
you may be familiar with the term
Lovecraftian horror or just Lovecraft
horror and some of you may be wondering
what exactly it means Lovecraftian
horror is a sub-genre of horror fiction
that focuses on the unknown a lot of
horror that we see today is based around
shock horror tons of jump scares and
gore that attempt to shock the audience
into disgust now this may still be
present in some Lovecraftian horror but
the main premise is the cosmic fear of
the unknown to summarize what I mean we
as humans like to think that we're an
advanced civilization but there is so
much yet to discover
well of Crofton horror takes the things
we cannot explain which happens to be a
large portion of reality and fills them
with the worst things imaginable it
plays around with the idea that there
are things in our own universe that we
cannot see terrible things that we are
blissfully unaware of but what if there
are creatures and monsters out there
that are so huge that we appear as
nothing more than a tiny speck it's a
type of horror then unless it's very
primitive fear the idea that we as
humans are no longer at the top of the
food chain the idea that human concerns
desires and even our hopes and fears are
completely irrelevant in the wider
concept of the universe and the cosmos
these deities and creatures that love
Kroft and others managed to create our
multi-dimensional entities that can
appear across several planes of
existence at the exact same time now as
its name would suggest the genre is
named after HP Lovecraft the first
author to really shape and pioneer the
genre born in 1890 Howard Phillips
Lovecraft was an American author that
was fairly unknown he was mostly
published in small magazines and it
wasn't until after his death that
Lovecraft became one of the most
significant horror writers of the 20th
century Korona plov craft took quite an
interest in Roman and Greek mythology
with his earliest piece of work being at
the age of seven when he took Homer's
Odyssey and combined it with other
mythological stories creating his own
unique style he's worked to get immense
of the supernatural and pre-human events
and then combine them of the
extraterrestrial many saw the work of
Edgar Allen Poe is one of Lovecraft's
biggest sources of inspiration over the
years the work of HP Lovecraft covers
many themes including superstition
religion fate forbidden knowledge
civilization under threat the risk of a
scientific era
race/ethnicity and claws but what made
love cross work so recognizable
was his use of cosmic ism the philosophy
that what we considers ordinary life is
nothing more than a thin layer covering
reality a reality that is so alien and
abstract to us that even attempting to
understand it would drive an ordinary
person insane one of La Crosse most
celebrated stories is the call of
cthulhu which follows an all-male cult
that sacrificed women and children in
the names of the gods they worship the
great old ones when members of this cult
are eventually arrested they find out
that the cult awaits the return of the
great Cthulhu laugh Groff wrote over 100
stories with the Call of Cthulhu is the
one that many consider to have started
the obsession of Lovecraftian horror
Lovecraft actually never intended for
Cthulhu to be pronounced the same way we
pronounce it today he also himself
pronounced the clue which definitely
isn't roll off the tongue the same ways
Cthulhu does the work of HP Lovecraft
then the creatures and deities created
by himself his friends and many of his
fellow authors have influenced writers
directors and game developers from all
around the world some of the recent
Lovecraft inspired films include cabin
in the woods in the thing those of you
who have played order Warcraft or even
blood-borne would know that these are
games that have Lovecraftian influences
littered throughout them just like in
the Call of Cthulhu and the actual
mythos that surrounds a work of HP
Lovecraft now has somewhat of a cult
following I know this video has been
fairly short but it was intended as a
brief explanation of Lovecraftian horror
and the man behind it all so for those
of you who have been asking this is me
announcing that we will be exploring the
Cthulhu Mythos in the weeks and months
to come if there are any creatures or
deities from life cross work that you'd
like me to cover then now is the time to
let me know in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology in
fiction explained
[Music]